welcome back to las vegas now it is
where your pajamas to work today
hence the outfits are pj's on here at
work all right she's coming off an
incredible breakout year and now she's
the first black woman
to co-host the acms yes mercedes talked
with country star
mickey guyton about the honor of being a
new mom and how she almost gave up
country music
you're hosting the acms can we do a
dance like to celebrate
we're dancing we're dancing hair flip
how did this happen someone called you
did you get a text what happened
you know i was filming promo and
keith urban called me
on my phone and was like hey mickey
would you like to co-host the acms with
me and i was like do i have a pulse
and here i am i probably should have
thought about that first because i've
never hosted anything
before in my life but i'm here and i'm
so excited congratulations on
on just what a couple of years it's been
for you
i think that so many people are looking
up to you as just
someone who is breaking barriers
destroying glass ceilings
how has it been for you you know
well it's all happened loved and stuck
inside which is crazy
but you know i've been pursuing country
music for
10 years and the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing
over and over and over again and i was
just pounding the pavement doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and it wasn't until i had this
conversation with my husband telling me
that i was running away from everything
that makes me different and i need to
embrace that
so i changed my whole way of thinking
scrapped everything that i had ever
tried before and started writing my
truth and
everything turned around to the point
where i'm standing up here
and going to be hosting the acm awards
which is
insane to me so my husband's the smart
man who were some of your inspirations
in the country world and out of the
country world
so i love dolly parton i love leann
rimes faith hill martina mcbride
shania twain i love whitney houston i
love ccynums i love mariah carey
any woman that has a big voice i'm just
obsessed with
now some of those names that you
mentioned have residencies here
in las vegas is a residency
something you would ever consider in las
vegas
of course if they just would have me i
would definitely pack up my little bags
with my husband and son and and do a
little residency out there
any any dirt on keith urban any behind
the scenes is he like
what's he like behind the scenes oh man
he's such a horrible guy
i can tell he seems like oh my gosh i
don't i
there's no like keith is like a freaking
saint
he's such a nice loving human like they
say don't meet your heroes because
they'll disappoint you
not keith how many outfit changes are we
going to have
and can you give me some colors that we
may see well you know i love a good
color like i
there you there's magenta there's
why is there a yellow outfit in there i
can't remember there's a lot of outfits
i have a really pretty white dress off
the shoulder
there's so many great like i'm trying to
give like diana ross vibes is my goal
will i do that i don't know oh
i'm sure you'll bring that and more good
luck to you
one more time the happy dance for the
acm you're hosting
your hostess
oh my gosh